okay guys let's get right into it Gavin
Hoey I'm very well thank you
Ben nice to see you the the most
interesting aspect of playing a
Christian Wulff the most interesting
aspect was the research I did with
people who are on the autism spectrum
and the contributions they made and the
insane I got into their life and the
stuff that I cited they were to have a
character as a protagonist in the movie
who was on the spectrum that was really
satisfying and I took that research that
Gavin and I did together with me and and
used it for the for the whole shoot it
was invaluable very cool now in the
trailer Gavin Christian's compared to
Mozart Picasso and Einstein I give them
that which leads to the question which
which has been most like in real life
which which one of those personalities
there's no fourth option can you answer
I don't know after working with him for
a while
Einstein Picasso Mozart
I guess I've heard you know in his
prodigious piano talents okay so you
play this accountant how in real life
are you good with numbers you're good
with Matt I'll pretend I can't really
kill a man with no no I wasn't gonna go
there I wasn't gonna go there do math
maybe the movie out of it but it was a
lot of fun pretending you can't help
your kids out with their math homework I
can help my kids out when I kiss or in
fifth grade right okay so that's time
level not Picasso finger painter
are you smarter than a 5th grader though
I'm right now tied okay he was a push
I'm working with JK John Lithgow jeffrey
tambor all those veterans in the in this
field of acting what was that like oh it
was it was fantastic I was very grateful
that they all were willing to you know
join the join the party and you know
once we did all the preparation and all
the work really I just sit back and
watch them do what they do so
brilliantly and JK is well got that him
along there as well okay yeah I'd seen
Jake I actually went to see the opening
night of on a Friday night of whiplash
and night after I saw the film and I'd
know JK's work of course but I walked
out and I called Lynette Howell a
producer I said you got to get me a
meeting with Jackie I want to cast him
is ray down to one minute already this
goes fast you're in a very committed
relationship with Matt Damon what's the
secret to that long-lasting Hollywood
relationship pen I don't know you know
Matt and I we just we have good sex good
real sex not acting so so he placed the
Picasso and you're the genius we gotta
get over this last question if he was in
the Justice League who would you think
he would portray who Christian Wulff no
no Matt I fell again you don't have to
ask him
perfect guys thanks so much